foreign
's going to start off this hour in
Atlanta Georgia hi Tom welcome to the
Ramsey Show hey Dave how are you better
than I deserve sir what's up in your
world
well I have a question for you and I
hope all's good in your world but um I
recently sold a company and finally have
enough money to pay off mortgages if I
wanted to and I wanted to know should I
do that or should I keep them financed
okay
I have a home under construction it's a
construction loan at three and a half
percent which is going to change if I
close with them under uh 15 or 30 year
mortgage to approximately five and a
half percent and I have the funds to pay
it off and I just needed to know should
I pay it off so what is that pile of
money that you got
um it's a nice chunk of change in it to
pay off the house I don't think it would
affect my lifestyle how much did you get
Tom I'm not allowed to say those exact
numbers why who who Who's Who your mama
told you you couldn't no no no I'm under
a confidentiality agreement oh okay was
it seven figures what are we talking
here north of a million
yeah okay well hey the reason I was
asking was congratulations well thank
you very incredible well done touchdown
Tom well done hey it was a touchdown
very happy 20 years fine how old are you
53 good for you and how much is the
mortgage balance gonna be
um it'll be with
June without
having worth about 2 million because
I've already put in a chunk okay so the
the chunk of change under
confidentiality is well north of 5
million then
it's a good number yeah okay all right
so so you can pay this off and still
have a big old pile of freaking money
that's that's what I want to make sure
before I move forward in this so here's
the thing
a good way sometimes for me uh and I use
it a lot personally to decide if I want
to keep something
or if I want to invest in something is I
reverse engineer it okay let's just
pretend your pile of money was five
million dollars and you had a million
dollar mortgage okay and so if you pay
off the mortgage you know you've got a
pile of four million dollars and you
have a paid for two million dollar house
okay is that right there I got my
numbers right didn't I well yeah
assuming assuming my assumption about
the confidentiality close Okay so anyway
that's our pretend scenario and now if
the house if they're let's reverse
engineer it let's pretend that you had a
two million dollar paid for house and
you had four million dollars in
Investments would you go borrow a
million on your paid for house
so that you had five million in
Investments
no same difference
fair enough and that tells me what see
see what I mean by reverse engineering
it so you can even do that with a boat
that's sitting in the driveway okay the
boat's worth ten thousand dollars if I
sold the boat I'd have ten thousand
dollars let's pretend I got ten thousand
dollars in the pile in the middle of the
table would I go buy a boat yeah I love
boats okay then don't sell your boat but
no of course I wouldn't buy another boat
I hate the stupid boat well then it's
time to sell the boat it's taking up
space in the driveway so you just
reverse engineer it and that's a sunk
cost analysis yeah this is a a good
situation to have but a lot of people
Dave what they see on paper is well Dave
if I invested that money I can make more
than the mortgage interest wouldn't that
be the smart thing to do and the
interesting thing is when we did that
larger study of millionaires ever done
in North America 10 167 of them the
number of them that borrowed on their
house to invest and as a result built
wealth was precisely zero we couldn't
find one
not even one that said I became a
millionaire because I maximized The
Leverage on my personal residence and
put that money in mutual funds not one
well the millionaire guy on on Tick Tock
told me differently Dave well that's
because not all those people tell the
truth well he had an online course that
was going to show me how to do it I know
a thousand dollars
oh that's how he made his money not
through leveraging debt that makes sense
yeah
it just you know if I
that's why we put stuff on Tick Tock I
mean I was going to avoid Tic Tac it
dropped that whole thing brought me nuts
and we just started flooding it with
Ramsay stuff to try to flush out
yeah just flush out some of the sewage
if you just take up the space with clean
water the sewage has to go somewhere
else you know it's just oh my gosh so we
thought okay we can either ignore this
sewage mess or we can just put a bunch
of cleanliness in there and oh these
people yeah I mean yeah you you watch
some of these guys honestly most of you
have good walking around since if you'll
take a second and just watch the body
language of a couple of these characters
you can 100 say they're lying
that their scenario is com I have 25
million dollars in mortgages and he's
got a baby on his hip oh you've seen
that one yeah that one went viral that
one's just so that guy's so lying that
he's not true you just watch it watch
his watch his eyes watch his mouth I
mean the guy is just you don't have to
be a FBI trained to figure out this
guy's not telling the truth okay so it's
just a straight up lie so uh honestly
people the data that we did in the in
this uh uh
millionaire study is airtight I mean we
used all of the research techniques we
use an outside research firm to make
sure we weren't doing confirmation bias
we weren't falling for some of the other
research methodology problems you can
get into because we actually know a
little bit about research and statistics
here at Ramsey and so we this this data
is so freaking solid that if you don't
agree with the conclusions you're what's
known as wrong so I mean you just got to
keep that in mind it's just straight up
the truth now uh so you know the number
of whole lot the number of millionaires
that made became millionaires because
they bought whole life life insurance
precisely zero
not one
the number of them that leased their
cars because this is what wealthy people
do not now some of them did rent lease
their cars but none of them told us that
it was anything but a mistake yeah okay
what was the dumbest thing you ever did
with money they would say I leased a car
bought a whole life policy these are the
things that kept me from Building Wealth
it's well it's so much simpler and more
boring than you ever thought it's it is
just put money in your 401k that's all
the funds pay off your house it's a
problem with this stuff it's too boring
Dave it's just really we need a sexier
approach make it real complicated do a
lot of math on a board real quick I need
a whiteboard and I need to be to dance
around and I need to do a double back
flip and get a Family Partnership Double
Twist Off the high board and you have to
come up with all this complicated crap
because that's what wealthy people do no
they don't they live on less than they
make they invest and they pay off their
house and if you want real money it's
what they really do build and sell a
company that's that's the American way
that's pretty cool now that's where most
of your billionaires come from
uh now if you want to study that's
Forbes 400 they're all today
billionaires and that's a thousand
million that's a different category
that's not a one to five million dollar
that's a thousand million and you're not
gonna get a billionaire with your 401k
boys and girls mathematically impossible
okay but you you know so there's some
other tricks involved some things
involved but none of them are the
stupidest but anyone can become a
millionaire is so much simpler
social media is where you're getting
your financial information even though
we're on there I'll just tell you it's a
struggle this is the Ramsay show